okay sometimes we will read a seemingly
insane headline related to trump in some
way and i'll assume oh it was taken out
of context it's not nearly as insane
that I'm sure the truth is not nearly as
insane is that headline makes it seem
and sometimes it's true that when you
look at the details the headline is
exaggerating but more and more with the
Donald Trump campaign the comments are
as crazy as they sound but sometimes the
headlines don't actually do justice to
how nutty what we are hearing from Trump
transition team members actually is I'm
talking today about our buddy Sean
Spicer Sean Spicer's the guy who couple
of weeks ago showed up all over
corporate media talking about the
completely imaginary a fantasy world
mandate that Donald Trump has according
to Sean Spicer obviously bogus you look
at the electoral vote numbers if you
look at the popular vote numbers however
you want to look at it I don't need to
rehash that there is no bigger anti
mandate than the one facing Donald Trump
right now Sean Spicer was interviewed
over the weekend he was asked whether
Donald Trump accepts the conclusions of
US intelligence that Russia is
responsible for hacking that sought to
damage Hillary Clinton and helped Donald
Trump during the 2016 election instead
of answering Sean Spicer chose to
redirect to the idea of brace ourselves
here we go now the idea of punishing
Hillary Clinton for trying to influence
the results of the 2016 election yes
Hillary Clinton was a candidate and the
whole point of an a campaign is to
convince people to vote for you so uh
earth to Sean Spicer that's what can
that it's do but he wants her punished
and here he explains why sort of I'll
just community still not there yet it's
not a question of not there yet Jonathan
it's a question of getting the
information everyone in the media wants
to jump forward and make a conclusion
based off other sourced information you
know anonymous sources that are coming
out of the Intelligence Committee he's
gonna do this right it's no longer
anonymous this it is no one will stand
what this says is that the DNC had a
problem with their IT security and
people tried to hack it and
to do a better job for Russians but the
fact that I didn't have we have it but
we're having part of a conversation why
aren't we talking about the influence
other influences on the election why
aren't we talking about Hillary Clinton
get debate questions ahead of time
that's a pretty valid attempt to
influence an election somebody giving
her to the debate questions any answer
of an election no not hey we haven't no
one's asking those questions and the
fact is is that everyone wants to talk
make Donald Trump admit to certain
things when are we gonna start talking
about the other side of this which is
what did Hillary Clinton do to influence
the election is she being punished in
any way what are we doing someone gave
Hillary not only the questions but the
answers to debate questions that part is
weird we're doesn't she know the answers
to the questions right every day he's
talking about when Donna Brazile prepped
her before one of the the debates in yet
Democratic primary right I mean that's a
lot different than what we have going on
here yeah it also has nothing whatsoever
to do with the National camp election
campaign against Donald Trump so spicer
allowed to dodge dodge dodge if you
can't get an ice and if you're a
journalist and you can't get an answer
from someone like Sean Spicer about
something like this you you may not be
able to do anything to get an answer but
I've dealt with this before and the way
you need to the handle it is to say also
you're not going to answer and then
usually that will put the person sort of
on the defensive bill often claimed to
have answered even though they really
didn't the fear of being accused of bias
is so crazy that corporate media hosts
are often afraid to even point out that
the question hasn't been answered the
big goal for the Trump Organization
right now the Trump transition the
president-elect administration call it
what you want is Hey look at this other
shiny thing redirection distraction and
Trump is doing the exact same thing on
Twitter saying that hey instead of
talking about the hacks Trump said on
Thursday we ought to get on with our
lives it is all misdirection and yet if
Trump is doing soliloquies on Twitter
it's hard to keep him to task and say
answer the question you have Sean Spicer
here saying what about punishing Hillary
Clinton for trying to influence the
election she was trying to win that's
not an answer and corporate media needs
to call it out and say you
we're not answering the question yeah i
think that tactic of not answering the
question and then trying to say that hit
what hillary clinton's doing is worse
yet kind of work during the campaign
trail because it was a lesser of two
evils campaign sure donald trump won the
election this is over with I mean you
have to take responsibility for your
actions now dude some journalism say
you're not answering the question I will
give you a third opportunity i'm going
to ask the question a fourth time that's
how you need to handle it and the
normalization of fake right-wing media
narratives is going to be one of the
greatest systemic dangers over the next
four years it has to be called out and
this is you know the micro story is Sean
Spicer shows up and he doesn't really
want to talk about what Trump thinks
about the hacking and he wants to
instead instead talk about Hillary
Clinton still by the way even though
she's lost she is no role to play here
whatsoever that's the micro story the
macro story is think about all of the
successful misdirection redirection and
fake narratives that have been
successfully created by right-wing media
working with in parallel with Republican
politicians death panels fake I mean
just absolutely fake huge huge impact on
voters the war on Christmas non-existent
I mean just fabricated out of thin air
lot of Republican voters think that's a
real issue thinking that supply side
economics is even remotely legitimate in
terms of the ways of it you know trickle
down and and the claims that the right
makes about how economics work it's it's
fake I mean it's a complete fake
narrative the Clintons are murderers
obviously that that's one that didn't
get as much traction but it got some
because of right-wing media Bernie
Sanders will tax you at ninety percent
obviously that wasn't true Planned
Parenthood selling baby parts completely
fabricated story out of thin air but
because of the oxygen that it was given
by right-wing media even right-wing
media that didn't completely say hey
this is true but continuing to talk
about the controversy that was based on
just bogus doctored video gay marriage
will ruin straight marriage still
waiting for examples of that uh and then
you know Hillary Benghazi is another
example this really works Pat this is
something that we need to be prepared
for during the Trump administration and
mere fact checking is not going to be
the solution
yeah because I think the media a lot of
times / trays the issues as this side
says this and the other side says this
and you have to make your decision on
your own oh yeah instead of just saying
this is patently true or completely
false the the false choice and false
balance is a big aspect of this and I've
spoken about this before I'll just very
quickly give you one example so in an
effort to not appear biased corporate
media might say today we're talking
about climate change we're going to
bring on two panelists one is a climate
scientist who like ninety nine point
seven percent of climate scientist
believes that human activity on earth is
impacting the climate the other is a
scholar from the such-and-such Institute
which if you google you realize is a
climate denying climate science denying
right-wing funded think tank who
believes like 0.3% of climate scientists
that humans are not having an impact
let's have a debate guys it's
fifty-fifty its balance this is what's
called fairness that is false balance
Pat and that can be just as biased or
damaging the people's understanding of
news stories as as just overt bias
editorially by news stations and people
don't get that yeah i mean the correct
way to portray that would be that the
client the person that believes in
climate change in that it's man-made
gets to speak ninety-seven percent of
the time that would be the way to do it
i think was john oliver who you have
pretty good he's sort of outlining this
in any case Sean Spicer obviously off
the rails of Hillary Clinton being
punished it just it's all nonsense but
the bigger story is we need to be
piecing together how we're going to
manage the next four years to stop
Trump's insanity and I'll talk about
that after the break gamefly is sort of
like Netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low use price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with reach
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s